wer weiß schon heute
jeder tag ist
wer weiß schon
morgen sind wir mal wieder alles neue
geht
so liebe freunde wussten ja an der oper
in münchen und hinter uns die
maximilianstraße
straße münchens vielleicht straße
deutschlands
und wir schauen heute mal leute zu wie
sie in der vorweihnachtszeit geschenke
einkaufen
mit lederjacke mit mehr als kragen
21 ausgewandert euro
entschuldigen sie dass ich kurz eine
frage zu weihnachten stellen nein ich
keine zeit panik weihnachten weihnachten
eine freie dürftigen schon die frage zu
weihnachten stellen was war denn das
schönste weihnachtsgeschenk das sie
jemals bekommen habe
daran kann ich mich nicht mehr in
schönste geschenk war ein hund eine
karte für ein fußballspiel von der cdu
ein schlafanzug aus flanell und dazu ein
buch die burg der abenteuer ein trennen
kann dir sagen was das schönste
weihnachtsgeschenk ist dass ich jemals
verschenkt habe ja das war vor meinem
ersten verdienten geld einen ring an
meine mama was war das schönste geschenk
was sie jemand zu weihnachten geschenkt
bekommen haben
liebe
ja sehen sie der hat wirklich erkannt
und anerkannt was bedeutet für sie
weihnachten woher erholungspause was
bedeutet weihnachten für sie noch nicht
welches auto kostet 49 00 euro ich würde
mal sagen schöner kleinwagen im
vergleich zu einer kette
die halskette txt ihn nur einmal im jahr
wenn es hochkommt und ansonsten liegt im
safe zu hause und man weiß dass man hat
aber wirklich tragen tut man es nicht
wann haben sie das letzte mal für einen
geliebten menschen etwas gebastelt zu
weihnachten anstatt etwas zu kaufen das
ist schon sehr lange her ungefähr also
mindestens
zehn jahre früher hat mir schon hast du
da jetzt mal strecken dann vor einem
jahr kalender was will ich immer jedes
jahr eigentlich schön ich danke ihnen
eine frage eine ganz kurze frage
was bedeutet für mich weihnachten
einfach nur gut ausschauen aber
mehr viel zusammen oder seid ihr dann
schon wieder getrennt
keine antwort